everything in this country is sold
regionally so there's regional style
regional styles in different parts of
the country the suits that you get in
New York are not going to look like West
Coast suits so I always try to find the
store that that person that character
would shop at and just stick there so if
they have seven changes by all seven
changes there the difficulty is is
giving definition to a regular person
how do you find how do we find what's
interesting in that regular person's
life and give shape and color to it so
that it becomes interesting for the
viewer the cut of the cloth is is is all
that you need you put the zoot suit at
anybody and you're there you're in the
1940s the zoot suit itself lens I think
a certain stylistic elon you know to the
human body whether males or females wear
it something about the cut of the cloth
and and the style the inverted pyramid
the broad shoulders you know with the
tight cuffs that that project a feeling
of elevated consciousness if not
Highness to be high you know is to be
wearing the zoot suit when Marty and I
were mixing it you know you watch the
movie over and over and over again when
you're mixing it in color timing it and
we just we started really looking at the
ties and saying my god she made such a
transition between these vol very vulgar
ties in the beginning and they're all
real by the way she bought them all in
secondhand stores are actually from the
time and then they by the time we get to
the end of the film they're wearing Wall
Street ties but leather it's a beautiful
transition just with ties and then
there's all kinds of other things she
did but yeah she prefers a good
historical film yeah we're telling the
story with every shirt tie lapel collar
stand collar length button open it's
just really the most interesting job